how many of the things that you're going
to say tonight are going to be
exaggerations and lies how much a
closed-off are you what's the exact
relationship with your mother ah sorry
good with money is it early in the state
to ask what your deal is
so really when's the last time you sent
a dick pic do you actually find me funny
here are you just trying to sleep with
me how fragile would you say your
masculinity is so how drunk are we
getting tonight
how drunk an I get before it's a
turn-off for you and you have off on any
excess was your ex crazy or were you an
[ __ ] are we having sex tonight fat
laughs I did earlier and daring or
annoying wait so how accurate would you
say your dating profile is to your real
life you give me some examples so I know
you're smart like that's so funny
is your apartment creepy this is going
so great how many dates have you been on
this month ten fifteen thirty how much
bad you did mine are you willing to deal
with why is every friend you mentioned
female so how much porn do you watch do
you always brag like this or are he just
earlier you said I looked hot in this
dress did you mean like good hot or
[ __ ] hot or were you just being polite
is your mother awful you seem like such
a good guy is this all [ __ ] I'm
gonna have to fart right now how good is
your sense of smell oh so you're gonna
call me when exactly how quickly are you
looking to make me your girlfriend and I
want to quick I don't want to slow
either I love your beard how here use
your back if I have sex with you tonight
you going to touch me this is so great
now how are you gonna summarize this
date to your friends go cliff jumping
whoa check out the waterfalls that'll be
great
that sounds amazing how do you feel
about kids this was really really fun
can you give me a general sum up of what
I talked about tonight I just want to
make sure you were listening
Wow